good morning John it's Monday September
13th I woke up this morning at about 4
o'clock in the morning not because I had
to actually because I had to I really
had to cuz I really had to pee
unfortunately between me and the
bathroom was this freaking spiral
staircase luckily I did not fall down it
that or any of the other four times I
had to get up and go pee but that is
neither here nor there John the reason
why there's a spiral staircase between
me and my bathroom is because I am in
San Francisco and I am in San Francisco
to go to YouTube there's some legitimate
confusion about where YouTube is like
YouTube to me is on my desktop it's a
non-physical digital internet place but
in the physical world YouTube could be
the place where all of the ones and
zeros that make up this video and all of
those other billions of videos actually
exist but I have no idea where that is I
actually think that that might be a
secret like nobody knows where that is
but if you ask Google Maps if you type
YouTube into Google Maps
it says 901 cherry which is where I am
right now welcome to YouTube that was
Rick Silvestri nee who works at YouTube
and was giving me a little tour of
YouTube and who was very clearly a giant
nerdfighter which was pretty cool to see
my first thought upon approaching
YouTube HQ with yeah this would be the
coolest place to work ever these guys
literally it must just sit around and
make youtube more awesome and watch
YouTube videos during all of the moments
when they're not having nerf gun fights
huh the reality is very different these
are people who get up early drive to
work put in 8 to 10 hour days making a
playground for the rest of us to play in
it's all very normal there's office
politics and some people don't put in
all the work they should put in and a
lot of people don't get recognized for
all the great work that they do do Dyke
every time I say that I have to think do
do it's a place in the real world is
that it's also just a place where people
work don't get me wrong it's not
dunder-mifflin they've got a massage
room and scooters and a tiki bar and a
gnome and a mini golf course and a
youtube logo made of wallets and arts
grass on the roof but it's not magical
and it's not evil either it's just
people mostly very cool and talented
people but just people and then we're
gonna place in John it's weird to put a
street address to youtube.com which is
so very obviously to the rest of us a
web address because not on one cherry
isn't where YouTube is YouTube is right
here in front of all of us right now
what 901 cherry is is a place where
people work really hard making this
place this weird non-physical place
possible and I am very thankful to the
people in that place for making this
possible and I'm also very thankful that
they know as well as I do that they're
just a bunch of people in a place
helping to create something much bigger
than that John I'll see you on Wednesday